in about seven months the Las Vegas
Strip will Echo with the sounds of
formula one but bringing Grand Prix
racing to the core of our Valley it's a
major challenge but it isn't the first
time Las Vegas streets have been turned
into a race track 16 years ago downtown
had its own brush with Motorsports John
langler looked into it looking back at
what went right and what went wrong
[Music]
this is the corner of Maine and
Bonneville speed limit around 30 miles
an hour
16 years ago it was a little more this
was part of 2007's Vegas Grand Prix
circuit the old champ car series came to
town a nearly two mile race track snaked
through downtown Las Vegas we're having
fun you know it's like icing on the cake
this is great one of the driving forces
behind the race Dale Jensen what we're
doing is we're throwing a big party and
we just happen to have a race that
breaks out the Phoenix businessman has a
slightly different take on the race
today the bad side was what it cost me I
mean it that was expensive at the time
champ Carr was one of the top racing
series in the country Paul Tracy was one
of its top drivers the Canadian also
called Las Vegas home at the time kind
of the start of revitalizing the
downtown all the potential was there it
just didn't didn't last back in 2007
Jorge Cervantes was Deputy Public Works
director we've been having almost weekly
meetings with a lot of property owners
today he's the city manager it was a big
effort uh we hadn't really close down
that portion of downtown before I think
a lot of planning a lot of different a
lot of people have pulled this off early
on Jensen had setbacks what sales do we
have everybody was kind of well we
haven't got them yet as race weekend
started there were 40 000 or so fans
more watched for free along the streets
[Music]
treats were a problem road crews had to
cut down the crown in the road along
Ogden race cars were taking flight the
track was really actually a really nice
Street course while competitors enjoyed
the track layout the public complained
about getting around the closures how do
you keep uh businesses going and how do
you keep people circulating while all
this being set up the race was supposed
to come back for two more years except
after the the problems we faced getting
the sponsorship and those type of things
for the race I just didn't have the
stomach to go try it again
Jensen lost a lot of the six million
dollars he put in then the champ car
series went away after the season had it
all together Vegas Grand Prix was one
and done a shame really because you know
I think it you know it had great
potential
this November the much bigger Formula
One Circus Comes To Town it's a chance
for Las Vegas to give street racing
another high-profile try they said that
it's going to be the first time Nevada
had a race on the strip and I was like
wait a minute we did we did have a race
on strip it was successful in that it
was a good race I ended up losing but
whatever
Jensen says in 2007 the Las Vegas Strip
was unavailable for his race the same
was the case for formula one's first
visit to town in the early 80s he hopes
to come back to town for our big event
this November